[موسيقى]
هناك جزء من العالم في
الدائرة القطبية الشمالية حيث لا يأتي ضوء النهار
بسرعة أو بسهولة
[موسيقى]
فصول الشتاء الباردة القارسة تكفي
لجعل لمعان الشمس يختبئ تحت الأغطية
لفترة أطول قليلاً في النهاية على الرغم من أن
كل شيء يأتي إليه الجميع  الحياة
في أسعد الطرق التي
يواجهها الناس هنا ليس فقط اليوم
بل يحتضنونها وكل ما يجلبه في
روفانيمي فنلندا
طريق مهجور طويل يبدو إلى
أي مكان أن ثبات الفنلنديين
الذين يعيشون في هذه الظروف معروف جيدًا
بعد كل ما يعيشون فيه
ظلام الشتاء الدائم مثل
صقيع الثلج أو المطر ودرجات الحرارة
عادة ما تكون متجمدة ، يتطلب الأمر نوعًا خاصًا
من الأشخاص لتحمل كل هذه
الكمية وهنا في لابلاند لديهم أيضًا
منزل سانتا كلوز والرنة وضعوا
ذلك في الخليط و  هناك
روح فريدة لأولئك الأشخاص الذين يعيشون
في القطب الشمالي يا سيدي
للوصول إلى قلب هذا المكان ، يجب
أن أبتعد عن وسط المدينة
إلى هدوء الغابة حيث
قاعدة
[موسيقى] الرنة
هنا هي أكثر من مجرد رمز
لعيد الميلاد ، فهناك صلة خاصة
بين حيوان الرنة والبشر جيدًا
عمرها آلاف السنين
ويجب أن أفهم إذا كنت
سأقدر روفانييمي لابلاند والدائرة القطبية الشمالية
نحن نذهب إلى الداخل أيضًا ثم
بدأنا في السياج الذي يؤذي أشياء
الرنة التي تؤذي أشياء رعي الرنة
هذا هو lickin
هذا lickin كلمة القضيب ، إنه يا
الله يا الله ، وقت العشاء ،
رعي الرنة هو أسلوب حياة
لسالي عندما يسير الرنة
لا يحدث.  لا يذهب إلى هذا العمق في الثلج إلا
أن معرفته برعي الرنة تكمن في
أعمق التقاليد في عالم الرنة
، حيث يأمر الذكور
بشهر واحد في السنة ،
واسمها إيفا ، واسمه ويلي
ويلي ، يجب أن يكون لدى كل راعي غزال الرنة
واحد على الأقل من الرنة البيضاء  في بلده / لها
لأن هناك الجان الذين يعيشون
على الأرض في حالة فتاة طيبة
جيدة ثم تدور حول القطط تأخذ
قرن الوعل خذ قرن الوعل
هذا كل شيء  أصعب مما تبدو عليه
[موسيقى]
العلاقة القديمة مع حيوان
الرنة والطبيعة تكاد تكون روحية كما لو كان
الحيوان مبنيًا حرفيًا
في تصميم المدينة الذي تراه
قد احترق تمامًا
خلال الحرب العالمية الثانية عندما
أعيد بناء المدينة  من قبل المهندس المعماري الفنلندي
ألفار آلتو ، قام بتصميم
البنية التحتية على شكل
رأس حيوان الرنة ، وطرق المدينة من
القرون ، والاستاد المحلي هو العين
مكان يسكنه حيوانات الرنة
ومدينة مصممة باسمهم ما يمكن أن
يكون أكثر ملاءمة للمسؤول
مسقط رأس سانتا كلوز